the raiders are coming off a thrilling
overtime win over the ravens last night
and today they're giving back to the
community kevin martin explains how
yeah thanks guys less than 24 hours
after last night's thrilling overtime
win i'm joined by safety jonathan abram
jonathan here here today out in the
community like i said after last night's
win
why is it so important for you to be
here today i'm just trying to give back
to the city of las vegas um trying to
make sure you know have an impact on the
kids you know something that you know a
lot of people you know i come from i
didn't get a chance you know do things
or see things like this or have
opportunities like this so just trying
to do my part and help out as much as i
can and i know you're a father does it
make it that much more important to give
back yes yes it makes it that much more
important because i have a kid so i know
what it's like you know she's a lot less
you know more fortunate than you know
most so we try to do much as we can help
out and is it are you still reeling
after last night or is it just on the
next one business as usual oh
it's fun to know so now we're worried
about being 1-0 next week thank you so
much jonathan i appreciate it reporting
live it's spreading preserve kevin
martin eight sports now